hey guys merry here with Mike McCarty at
PAX Prime 2015 and we just got hands-on
on the shooter MOBA hybrid battle more
yeah multiplayer shooter I think they're
calling it I don't know but yeah we
played for different characters and we
got to play the co-operative campaign
today which was a first for me and you
yeah I don't had hands on it before
we've seen the trailer isn't really
indicative of what we play great they're
focusing more on the competitive part
but we've got to play together to get
today and had a little bit more of a
kind of like a borderlands vibe to it
because you're basically just i but
they're basically just giving you
various tasks to do to complete where
there's destroy something or protect a
giant the machine that that's got a
quirky sense of humor yeah there's
definitely a variety of objectives
there's the defending your escorting
this robot and you can also upgrade the
robot which is cool and he was spending
these shards you're collecting which
you're kind of short term currency you
could give it a tote air it you can give
it like a healing aura around it which
you know yeah shield which was like at
the cheapest one but yeah so we and then
you also get to the end and you have to
defend its like a hormone almost and
like you know there's waves of enemies
coming at you from three different
directions and I really liked how the
characters played into it I'm you played
Phoebe which is that like the male a
ballroom dancer that's right that's a
good description you got hands on four
different characters to each and I'm
gonna refer to them by their silhouette
because nobody really cares about their
name it's there they're just wildly
different and Phoebe was this whole room
sword-bearer she was melee yeah she's
like force bloating swords or something
that's right she's pretty wild uh but I
didn't really enjoy her that much I
found that most of the bad guys had guns
right so having something that gives you
a bit more
it was better in that campaign at least
for me so I actually enjoyed my second
character much better or ND i think for
ND forearm buddy's like a poor arms
alien yeah looks like a little weird
alien running around shoots beams of
damage that you can shoot out as
distance i also had a move where I
basically shoot myself backwards and
then just left a trail of damage so
anything following me would get hurt if
it was chasing me I was really cool so I
like that character much better without
you yeah I like Miko a lot he's the
support character he's got that mushroom
mushroom had yes as you would refer to
him he's you know he can I cast the
fungus fungus among us ability I think
that's a Chili Peppers album also but
you cast the mushroom and then it just
has this healing like dome around it
which is super helpful I remember there
was a few times when I could just heal
you it looks like I was hurting you i
was i was like I think I'm healing her
but yeah your help was recharging so
it's great but I always tend to
gravitate towards the poor character so
I like Miko and then I also played mark
he he was there really weird run he had
this sprint where it's really robotic
can't see ya fancy robot guy steampunk
yeah he was like that he was a range of
salt character and a sniper like the
pistol that transforms into a sniper
rifle and you're actually aiming down
the sights and then you can operate it
to just be this like one shot kill ya oh
and all there's definitely a variety
between characters that's right yeah I
really enjoyed I think what we liked so
much about me co-write was what a huge
difference that made to the gameplay it
wasn't a standard character you have
lots of different types of characters it
makes it very different than Borderlands
it makes it way more like team fortress
or a sure to get your heavy class you
have your assault class you have a
healer and and that's neat changes the
dynamic of the gameplay instead of
running around looking for loot we're
running around just attacking and and
getting all these different things done
world that we need to get done to me
that made the dynamic of the game way
more fun but the different character
that you play to me it changes whether
or not I enjoyed the game sure I enjoyed
the game way more is that four-armed
alien then I did the ballroom Italian
now yeah whatever it is it's got four
arms and it was so rad yet but way more
fun to me than a melee character which
gave me wheless range to run around
killing sure so all in all I think it
was definitely a different feel than the
competitive multiplayer I think I prefer
competitive multiplayer at this point
still that's how I like those games to
be played but the co-operative campaign
could be a good break from that it
seemed I think the difficulty on the
demo we played might've been turned down
but it seems sort of easy especially as
a sniper character when the other
characters are kind of when the enemies
are kind of you know absorbed in what
the ballroom sword wielder I alien is
doing I'm like oh say she's an alien as
well um yeah and there but yeah so in
general it was it was a new take on the
game that I hadn't played before and it
was kind of interesting to see how that
dynamic plays out between characters and
game modes yeah it's gonna be really
interesting to see where they take it
from here I agree with you it looks like
they're gonna focus way more on the
competitive aspects of it but the
cooperative campaign mode is a great way
to learn the different characters that
move or maybe just play with a friend
because it may be felt a little easier
maybe that's a great way to play with
somebody else who's not as familiar with
the game and still be able to enjoy it
with them sure so a lot more to be seen
here for the rest of your packs coverage
be sure to stay
gamespot.com
you